هل البيت الأبيض لديه رد فعل على
هذا أه وهل لديهم أي خطط للرد
بشكل جيد السؤال سيكون ما مدى
خطورة أه
أثر هذا الحدث كان مهمًا
لإدراك أننا ما زلنا لا
نعرف خطورة هذا الهجوم  على افتراض أنه
كان هجومًا انتحاريًا ، وهذا
يعني تحديد تأثير
عدد الضحايا على الجانب الأفغاني على
الجانب الأمريكي إذا كان هناك أي
، ومن المرجح أن يحدد حجم هذا
التأثير ما إذا كانت
الولايات المتحدة تشعر بأنها مضطرة
للرد أم لا  لكن هذا هو السيناريو الكابوس ،
هذا هو نوع
سيناريو الكابوس الذي كانت الإدارة
قلقًا بشأنه مع وصولهم إلى
نهاية عملية الإخلاء هذه ، حيث
ستزداد هذه الثغرة الأمنية حيث
كان لديك أشخاص يائسون يحاولون الوصول
إلى المطار المزدحم حول تلك البوابات
وهذا أحد أسباب
محاولتهم تشجيع الناس على
مغادرة المطار ما لم
يُصرح لهم على وجه التحديد بالدخول ،
لكن هذا هو بالضبط ما فعله الرئيس
بايدن  كنا قلقين
بشأنه بالطبع على مدار الأسبوعين الماضيين
حتى هذه اللحظة ، لم
يبلغنا عن وقوع إصابات ولم يكن لدينا أي
حوادث إصابات جماعية تشمل أفغان في
المطار ،
لقد غيّر هذا الموقف ،
هذا سؤال لا يمكننا ببساطة
إجابة الآن ، قد يعرف الرئيس
الإجابة لأنه قد
تم إطلاعه ولديه إمكانية الوصول إلى المعلومات التي لا
نعرفها ولكننا في وضع الانتظار والترقب ومن
المحتمل أن يكون البنتاغون في هذا الإحاطة 10 30
قادرًا على التخطيط
المزيد من التفاصيل حول حجم
الهجوم وسنرى ما إذا كان لدى البيت الأبيض
معلومات لإضافتها أيضًا